hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to in Lucy's eyes I
want to apologize for last episode I was
a blithering idiot I couldn't get out a
full sentence without stumbling over my
words so this time I've collected myself
and actually before I do that I'm gonna
turn up the gamma a little more because
I literally can't see anything at all so
might as well cheat just a tiny bit to
be able to see where I'm going still
looks pretty dark at least there's a
little something lighting my way because
otherwise I'm going to be screwed oh you
know what that's not well I mean I
wouldn't be able to see anything here
you know I honestly
yeah I'd feel bad doing that because
honestly I got a play true to the
experience because it's part of it it's
kind of been part of what's been so
scary about this it's just it's been so
dark I have no idea what's lurking
around every other corner like seriously
that big guy wouldn't have snuck up on
me if I had been able to see him if I
would have even been able to see myself
like go blurry vision from looking in
its general direction I've got the fear
burps right now
okay so crawling in a dark tunnel that's
a good thing
Oh what is that always had the word from
penumbra our than a penumbral worm
aren't the penumbra worm ain't it I'm so
boned hello
speaking of bone this is dude whose
bones are those do I need this to define
it's dark this is gonna be a fun episode
I can already tell we're like going why
can't I see a damn thing I'm so gonna
run out of that hmm why why explain to
me why why do you feel the need to do
these things to me just let me live my
life in peace also is this still part of
my castle I'm still Richard the [ __ ]
Stein but why of cows
loading mines upwards I'm not going
upwards I'm going downwards and I don't
know why man like back at the there was
a junction there when going into the
archives that could have gone upstairs
there was another one that led out of
the area but I didn't go to that one
because I didn't think I needed to
well those are new sounds I just flew my
hair for bravery turned out ready for
this I'm not ready for Freddie
I'm not ready for Lucy apparently okay
never mind that sorry didn't mean to
disturb you
oh that's a monster oh no oh no oh no oh
no is it blind oh is it all blind oh oh
it might be a lie no but I'm not sure oh
oh I want off that ladder oh man remains
safe own ladder me save Lana be safe
okay okay oh okay
what's up doctor what are you doing what
are you doing what about what what the
[ __ ] was that
you saw that [ __ ] kept moving me
forward like a son of a [ __ ] oh hey I
got you blocked by a pillar ain't nobody
ever gonna see me what you doing over
there Dumbo huh stumbling around legs in
the dark like a loser
okay why can't I go up why can't I go up
any further oh because I'm on the wrong
side of it oh that would explain many
things okay I saw a glowy up here
oh is that the glad school
you're very stompy oh is that above me
what is that what is that sound
why is it so Rory how's Ella gizelle I
don't like this game don't I don't like
it the bad things happening in here
bad things are brewing and why did I
need this ladder
hopefully it's to get out of here but
not up to meet that dude
I mean obviously the clue on the paper
said upward oh that is what's you Oh Oh
No what do you got glowy eyes for douche
get them out of here yeah no eyein Logan
I'm looking at myself
okay as soon as he gets get out of here
get out of here get out of there I don't
have anything to throw so I can't
exactly make him vacate the vicinity
maybe if I just stare at a wall and hum
to myself mm-hmm hmm God that music is
so ominous it's so thumpy okay that's
not a good sound whoo-hoo oh no no no no
no oh no no oh yeah yeah oh no no I am
stuck okay
he no see me that's a bucket almost hit
that I would have died
Oh I mean like II mean like it ain't no
likey this game you know like you have
nothing fun okay please tell me he's
okay this leads oh this seems like it's
gonna be noisy he here okay so
apparently that doesn't work all right I
guess I gotta go around him
oh he's big oh he's big oh he's so big
oh he's big oh he's big oh he's right
behind me at his bag oh he's a grumbling
okay okay everything's fine
big man went away okay big mess coming
back okay big man went away okay
alright okay okay okay
he's just a thumping around aimlessly he
ain't gonna hurt nobody
oh boy nobody looks at him and his
magnificent packs oh no no oh yeah yeah
oh no no I'm just gonna slip right by
him he's never gonna know he's never
gonna know so what is all this thing I
like kid how do I get around him where
am I supposed to go a period us tense
tense II tense okay I see a ladder
safety ladder means safety ladder means
happy fun times
and I've even got a ladder in my pocket
I've got a ladder in my pocket and a
belly full of sunshine I'm gonna have a
happy fun day alive
he needs to stop doing that after I get
up a ladder he needs to stop randomly
making me go forward because that's
gonna kill me someday
where's tiny bucks to him honey my skin
has not been around here he's not
helping me on my adventure what did he
see my light okay is there any reason
for me to be up here besides his matches
and getting away from the douche oh oh
oh he sees me oh he sees me oh he wants
me Oh big man want me hey I was going on
the throw box on your head cuz screw you
watch this mister I can't climb a ladder
bonk or no jumped and hit my head what
is this box over here well I've got a
bone to pick with maybe with the pretty
lights over there well I don't know
about definitely when I get my hands on
that box
oh okay turned into Santa Claus that's
okay okay we're fine so apparently he
can see light otherwise being a big fake
fake oh wow check out the ladder tell me
that I'm fat momma Gunn denim look oh
stop moving for stopping for
oh he's he spinning his circle down
there cuz that what he's doing he's
totally spinning in a circle hello you
having fun you having fun down there
buddy
ain't no one's gonna judge you for
liking ballet it's awful admirable if
you ask me
super admirable okay to end this I think
I have to let him kill me cuz he might
be spawn hi oh oh god you're terrifying
oh geez you're so scary oh my god you're
terrified holy crap that's awesome
that's amazing that's really cool high
and down I go
is that guy different from the one in
the sewers before don't let him see you
he will break your bones okay so this
one's not blind it is different well
good I did not know that
hopefully he might have despawned which
will allow me to actually explore the
area and oh I was I like into oh I was
inches from it wasn't I oh oh okay no
okay I saw the broken lat
oh I was inches from it oh no I was
inches from it why can't I use this item
that way weight mean why can't I use
this item that way this seems obviously
what I'm supposed to do it's kinda right
they're all mix kill yo can I please no
fine there's got to be something else I
need to do then cuz this is stupid
so now that he's hopefully gone then
I'll be gone the reason I did that is
because it would have taken me forever
to figure out what exactly Oh down here
I didn't even see this path before then
again I probably could have runned it in
a panic scream down this way and
everything would have been fine but now
I got some room to breathe because my
heart couldn't have taken it anymore
did you want Margie Moo's heart to
explode I don't think so
also I was getting kind of used to it so
let's keep things fresh that's to make
me feel relaxed and then have it all
ripped away from at the last moment
where am I going what am i doing what is
this place this really bizarre like it's
hard to get an idea of what the layout
actually is because I don't often I
don't often get a good look can I put
this up here maybe no okay so I have a
feeling that maybe that's gonna help me
climb up somewhere you're just doing
oh oh ha oh come on okay maybe I just
climb up like a normal person and not be
silly let's get up there get up there
Danna oh you [ __ ] okay hep pop there we
go
God I got it got it okay now we got our
maybe we don't because that's my
personal choice and I know an influence
huh and oh just like that okay now we
get up here now we got up here there we
go okay
don't even know if that was the right
way that I was supposed to do that but
frankly I don't care I made progress I'm
making progress is what I'm trying to do
I don't want to stall out and go nowhere
you don't make me miss this jump okay
there you are you boy that ominous
rumbling I sure I'm glad a full
orchestra is always following me in
these horror games it sure brings the
ambience a little bit more so they can
endure my experience to the fullest oh
crap good oh I made him a tomato made
him a tomato made it I'm going upwards
just like the message told me even
though it garner even though I should
should have been not going downwards in
the first place why did I follow Lucy
down here oh here we go here we go yes
okay made progress might have missed
something down there but I don't care at
least I am home free and now there's
gonna be more monsters coming after me
this is what I have to deal with
everybody why wear a hat sometimes I
just want the freedom not after great by
my roof
what do you
what do you got for me game boy from me
where you it seems good am I eventually
gonna get out I could probably crawl out
of there and be home free but they're
gonna then again me being mr. Duchenne
himer I probably don't care about
anything other than finding my daughter
or getting revenge on my daughter maybe
getting revenge on my wife I don't know
I'm only assuming the worst in me cuz
frankly that's all I have to go on this
long tunnel usually means it's building
up to something big it's like a long
hallway is that blood or is that red
forget me good hello the Barons new
version of black powder is truly amazing
the new fluid form is much less stable
but a lost more effective we've been
able to carve out several paths several
hundred meters long in our production
rate is increased by an astounding
amount the ingredients are the same as
when creating black powder but the Baron
did something to the potassium nitrate I
think he boiled it in something we keep
it in glass jars now but be careful
cools off surprisingly slow potassium
nitrate charcoal and sulfur mix these
ingredients plates of fluid where you
want it to explode move away from the
explosive and watch it do its magic okay
so I need to make some explosives for
some reason why Oh probably to burst up
in one of these fences possibly unless
they already have a pre-mixed batch then
again I don't know why they would have
that why is this glowing Oh Oh
charcoal okay good good good good good I
mean I guess it's good maybe it's not
good but I think it's good then is this
okay
No so the glowy was actually in a good
place and I'm glad I noticed that so I
got charcoal I just need potassium
nitrate and saltpeter was the other one
okay okay okay I'm doing good good fine
nothing else here all right well fine
fine move 400 Oh debris is blocked away
I need to clear it so I need to explode
it is what you're saying
and Frank oh hey perfect an a seeing
that train okay good good good good okay
so I need just that I got charcoal and I
need sulfur where do I get sulfur sulfur
sulfur Oh Oh
sulfur sulfur himself a perfect perfect
easy everything's right here in front of
me oh okay Oh God chemical charged walk
very carefully let me just look in with
this match on this explosive material
just to make sure it mixed correctly
this looks like a platform oh wow
impressive okay cool we made progress
Domon end this episode here thank you
everybody so much for joining me on this
heart-attack adventure like really I
hope you're enjoying it because frankly
my heart is taking a beating you
especially in the beginning of this
sensor goddamn so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next one
Oh
okay okay back up